hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 6 video just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet this avatar aesthetic it
seems like they've gone with is like a
Daniel West costume via Megatron
transformers so it's like very metallic
very pointy and dangerous but just meant
to be more horrifying than previous
versions of the reverse-flash like zoom
so many comic book things happening in
this episode so they had the shade
character which actually debuted in
flash number 151 he's like an actual
character they also just reintroduced
him in flash rebirth but there was so
much about dual identities secret
identities like earth 19 Harrison wells
had the thing that masked his identity
so that he wouldn't be arrested in
public Caitlin's killer frost dual
identity and then Wally's dual identity
so beneath the plot in this episode
they're just trying to tell you that
everybody has like another secret itself
so when Julianne disappeared in the
episode everyone's like oh wait a minute
just as everything goes to [ __ ]
he's just nowhere to be found so we're
just waiting for a big reveal but they
won't actually reveal who dr. alchemy is
till episode 9 that's like when he'll
actually take the mask off so before
then they'll just be a couple more clues
about who he is but I'm still going with
the Julian Albert Albert Desmond
dr. alchemy twist from the comics so
it'll be like a variation of dr. alchemy
from the comics but let's do top 10 WTF
and comic book Easter eggs so number 10
they opened the episode like it's
Wally's TV show like we're back in the
flashpoint universe I am the flash it's
like the same way Grant Gustin does it
every week so you kind of have like this
cheesy wall-e scene where he's just
doing everything to help the city just
having a great time of it then he wakes
up tells Joe he's like super excited
about it like oh yeah I get to be a hero
but just like dude do you remember what
happened with magenta a couple weeks ago
she said she had the dreams she went to
alchemy so Joe is just like trying to
talk some sense into him
but the big metaphor of the episode is
that you can't ignore problems you have
to deal with them so number 9 Barry
comes clean to everyone about flashpoint
Wally and iris and even she's
disappointed like she thinks that
flashpoint iris is cooler than she is
and of course Wally's like I have to
have
powers now it got a little soapy for me
during this part but they're just trying
to get across that almost like the true
Wally is trying to claw his way out of
this husk here so I kind of ignored the
character stuff because we all know that
he's gonna become a version of the
speedster but the cut you know the real
question like Joe's fears number 8 will
he be the Wally that we know like the
good Wally or will it be a dark twist on
that so I will say they didn't make that
yellow Kid Flash costume and spend all
that money on it to only use it a couple
times so eventually you know whatever
ends up happening when he comes out of
the chrysalis even if it's something
super crazy he will eventually be Kid
Flash again on the TV show it just
remains to be seen like what happens
before he puts that costume on like if
they're gonna take some dramatic WTF
left turn where he goes super crazy for
a little while but number seven is the
cecile plot so if you couldn't tell
they're turning her into a pretty big
character on this show she also has a
daughter that's almost the exact same
age as Wally so it's like they're
telling you they're gonna introduce her
eventually I don't know if she's gonna
be a meta or anything like that I think
she's just gonna be another cool
character for them to interact with so
you can kind of feel the sexual
chemistry between the two of them
they're basically just trying to tell
you that you know maybe they're meant to
be together and if everything with dr.
alchemy and Savitt are doesn't rip them
apart
she'll effectively become Wally and
irises new mom but I always like when
they tease things that you know that
they'll have to pay off later or else
you know we'll just write like how could
you tell us about all these characters
and then not introduce them so
eventually we'll meet her daughter but
number six meet the shade so he's a meta
on the TV show but in the comics he
actually has like a measure of
immortality his powers work a little bit
differently they're just trying to
introduce like a more scientific
explanation for what he does like he
vibrates like Barry does to give the
appearance of invisibility so it's not
quite the same thing like his powers
don't come from the Speed Force but
functionally it looks almost like the
same thing but Harrison wells earth 19
Harrison wells is the person who gives
him the name oh we had a guy named shade
on r2 that had pretty much the same
powers so then number 5 Caitlin finally
comes clean to Cisco about her killer
frost powers she's going to use the
power dampeners for now but obviously we
know episode seven next week's episode
is called killer frost so there'll be
some big twists and she'll have to go
nuts and the big question is is will she
be able to stop herself from being evil
like the whole point here the whole
reason she's afraid is because she's
convinced that she's gonna be evil so
there's like a couple things that the TV
show hasn't explained like she gets
powers but is there like a psychological
component to her powers because
otherwise she'd totally be able to
control herself like she'd just be
making things cold absorbing energy but
the way the TV show is presenting it
it's like you know something is
happening inside her brain that's making
some other personality take over like a
killer frost personality so I'll
understand if you guys are just like a
little confused about that part because
unless they explain something different
she didn't get her powers from dr.
alchemy she got them because of
flashpoint so they just occurred
naturally after the Dark Matter
explosion olan vibe versus killer frost
I love that he doesn't tell her in the
way they colored this you can barely see
but they are wearing their full-blown
comic book costumes they they tease in
that other video that I posted last week
so these are what they look like they're
little blurry here but you can kind of
get an idea pretty pretty close to their
comic book personas just a slight twist
so either way we're gonna find out in
next week's episode like that episode 7
will completely explain where they're
taking the character I think it's gonna
be really interesting and know danielle
Panabaker is not gonna leave the show
like she's worried that she's gonna be
evil and have to leave she is still very
much a series regular so even if she
does go evil in the future she might be
gone for like an episode or two she's
still series regular she'll still be in
most of the episodes so number four I
will call shippers bait this is
basically like the biggest bait that you
could give Barry iris shipper fans where
he flat-out tells her there is no flash
without iris West so there I mean their
big thing in the comics so obviously we
knew that they were gonna get together
on the TV show eventually but this is
just them telling you oh yeah we are
totally doing the thing
so I'll understand if you guys think
that it was like a little cheesy like a
little heavy-handed the way they did
that but they just want to get that
across like they're definitely pursuing
Barry and iris this year but the thing
is when they
get all nice and cozy that's when the
villain comes in and does something
crazy so Savitt are is gonna get in the
middle of that so if you're not a big
fan of how soapy they're getting with
this relationship stuff just wait to see
what's avatar has to say about Barry and
iris trying to enjoy themselves he's
just that there's a long history in the
comics of evil flashes trying to go
after Flash girlfriends or wives so you
can imagine what the TV show is gonna do
with that they're gonna have a little
bit of fun with that idea let's see next
one flash versus shade actually wasn't
that big of a fight that was really just
a distraction for Wally West WTF so
number three
Wally versus Iris he just got knocked
the hell out BAM goes down like a sack
of potatoes
but they follow him to Alchemy's lair
and even though they were a little
heavy-handed with the twist like I wish
for you to all be away I did like the
way they set the stage like they had
that creepy atmospheric music in the
background like the follow was there or
chanting so it definitely reminds you of
the aesthetic of zooms lair in season 2
like if you're a really evil person on
the flash your lair has to have like a
certain level of dark grunge to it but
number two they apprehend alchemy but
Wally picks up the philosopher's stone
inactivates like the process of becoming
that other flashpoint self so he goes
into a chrysalis which is actually a
deep cut from Babylon 5 which they named
dropped on arrow so there is some meta
sci-fi crossover happening but if you
didn't watch Babylon 5 at the end of the
first season like one of the big
characters goes into this chrysalis and
undergoes this huge transformation and
it's like this really ominous portent of
things to come but it's not necessarily
a bad thing so the question is is what
will Wally look like when he comes out
will he just be Wally with flash powers
will he become kid flash or will he be
twisted inside like all the other people
who got their powers via dr. alchemy so
if you're wondering how the
Philosopher's Stone is able to give him
his flashpoint self give him those
powers that he had that other timeline
they'll explain that in future episodes
but it'll probably be some twist
we're like the Philosopher's Stone is a
remnant of that other timeline so don't
worry they'll totally explain that in
the future
episode just like they'll explain dr.
Alka mean the big twist behind him but
number one WTF obviously is Savitt are
the god of speed he's actually the name
savat are is the Hindu god of speed so
that was what they use that for in the
comics but you can see he's super
armored he's physically much bigger than
Barry so it's basically like a
motion-capture villain gorilla grodd's
style so there's like an actor in a
mocap suit when they're filming these
scenes and then they add the special
effects later so he looks kind of like
Megatron what we'll probably find out is
that you know he's a person underneath
there but he manifests his costume from
the speedforce the way they do it in the
comics like they just introduced that
idea in the rebirth comic but they did
confirm that the next couple of episodes
will like slowly tease savat are out but
really the big reveal in episode 9 is
gonna be dr. alchemy so there's still a
lot of dr. alchemy to come before they
roll hard on Savitt are but just in
general it seems like they're setting
savat are up to be the big challenge for
the second half of the season so that's
why we're only just seeing him now even
though he's been around this whole time
so you guys can let me know what you
think like what do you think of the look
of sabot are do you think that julian
albert is connected to dr. alchemy even
if he's not flat-out alchemy i think
there's gonna be a big twist from the
comics it won't be exactly like it is in
the comics with Desmond Albert but it'll
be pretty close so just a reminder that
there is a new episode of the flash next
week but everything else will be on
break at least for DC TV and they're
supposed to be dropping a new Justice
League trailer soon maybe they're gonna
attach it to fantastic beasts or the
wait till December to drop it but there
is a new Justice League trailer coming
soon so another big heads up there is a
new round of the DC giveaway that's
going on right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's just a $20
Amazon gift card so we'll do in episode
7 killer frost trailer video next
that'll post tomorrow morning and then
there's a new episode of arrow they're
gonna debut another big comic book
character so get hype it's gonna be a
lot of fun I was actually really happy
with this episode it'll be interesting
to see where they take this avatar
character it has a lot of potential but
they're really only just teasing him so
we'll see how close he is to his comic
book persona but obviously he looks a
lot different in the extra cool thing
here is the
nobody else can see him but Barry maybe
that's because he's moving so fast but
they'll probably explain that the more
they tease about well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for the
trailer for the big four night crossover
and you can click here to learn all
about Marvel's Inhumans TV show thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight